ladies and gentlemen
Ryan sickler
that's so nice
thank you la
thank you so much
oh that feels good
best that hug I never got from my mom
right there
that's it right there
I just want to say thank you first to
everybody in here whatever it took for
you to get in your seat tonight parking
babysitter some of you probably took
showers I appreciate it all right
now I know we have drinkers here but
where are the weed smokers there we go
all right those are my people right
there now I want to be clear about this
people think I don't drink it's not that
I don't drink I just don't drink a lot
like I'd say during the pandemic I might
have had three or four drinks okay now I
smoke weed all right now I don't smoke
daily but I do smoke nightly okay
I really had to reassess alcohol's role
in my life now I'm just talking about me
and I'm just comparing weed and alcohol
for me okay for me alcohol has always
been that bad friend you know I'm
talking about never have my back
full of terrible decisions you know just
a real piece of [__]
but weed weed's been the good guy weed's
been kind
weed's been thoughtful
and weed has humbled me when necessary
I've been smoking weed for almost 30
years now all right and in that 30 years
weeds never told me to do some of the
[__] that alcohol has told me to do
30 years not one time has weed ever said
to me
just go ahead and piss yourself right
here
it's fine
I'm pretty sure no one's even going to
notice
it is [__] horrible advice alcohol
horrible we would never tell me to piss
my pants
we would be like Ryan what the [__] are
you doing
your eight-year-old daughter doesn't
piss her pants man
behind the dumpster and get your [__]
life together man
God damn we
why you gotta be so good all the time
we'd help me out with a very serious
situation recently all right I'm a
single dad
and I had to go meet my daughter's
mother's new boyfriend okay yeah oh
right and you know that's never easy but
this is my life all right this can't be
just some normal dude this guy's got to
be a cop okay yeah
but I live here like you all he can't
just be a cop this motherfucker's got to
be California Highway Patrol
he's chips y'all
chip you understand I grew up watching
chips it's a core memory for me and now
I gotta go meet Ponch what are we
talking about
so obviously I'm insecure
and I'm nervous about this and I'm
talking to a friend of mine he's like
you know what just take a shot just one
just take the edge off and I was like no
there's no way I'm taking that [__]
alcohol over there with me I want to be
the best representation of myself okay
not just for me but for me and my
daughter we're a team I want the two of
us to look good I'm not drinking before
I meet this guy I'm smoking weed before
I meet his ass
and I'm glad I did y'all because when I
walked past that police cruiser
and I peeked in that window if I would
have drank alcohol alcohol no doubt
would have said bust his windows
and rub your dick on his walkie-talkie
[Music]
[__] alcohol I smoked weed the good
guy
the kind one
the caring one
and when I walked past that police
cruiser you know we said we said amen
tell me left his interior light on
he said I know you don't want to hear
this Ryan
if we're gonna break it all the way down
that's our tax dollars at work
why are you so good why are you so good
I'm a big football fan I love football
football is fun
unless you have an alcoholic friend who
roots for a shitty team like the Browns
you know what I'm talking about those
guys are the worst you know those people
I've been in their house before they
start getting [__] up
and the Browns do what they do every
week they start getting [__] up
and what's happening next that house is
getting [__] up
I'm watching these videos of guys on
YouTube throw TVs off their balconies
what the [__] are you doing
like do you really think we would ever
encourage me to tear my house apart no
weed lays right next to me on the couch
Roots my favorite team's on
says [__] to me like hey Ryan you know
it'll be really nice around here
some holiday hand towels
oh hell yeah we
let's Spruce this place up a bit
and we ain't done their weeds like I
ain't talking about just Christmas and
[__] man
it's all about all the holidays but oh
you know we're getting some Halloween
hand towels in here go get me some jack
o'lanterns and candy corns hanging off
that of it
well get me a scared black cat
there's Mr Good Guy weeds like hey let's
not forget about our Jewish friends man
I'm like oh Hanukkah hand towels
I don't know where to get those but I
want to be festively appropriate God
damn it
and here comes that [__] alcohol you
know what alcohol would say to me
alcohol would say we're gonna wipe our
ass on those hand towels
and weeds ready for that weed's like
used to think
Thanksgiving
don't use the brown hand towels at her
place
now here's the real thing about wheat if
I'm being honest weed would have me help
an old lady across the street okay
alcohol would have me ask her out all
right
that's where it's at right there okay
now the thing I love about weed too is
it's not too strong tonight I'm gonna
[__] go out after these shows I'm
gonna smoke a bunch of weed and weed's
gonna rock it with me all night long
till the wheels fall off weed's Gonna
Take Me Home Tonight
yeah weed's gonna put me in bed
and then weed's gonna get in next to me
pull the covers up outside spoon me all
night tonight
I'm sleeping like a baby tonight
okay not alcohol
wants to go out all night too rock until
the wheels fall off alcohol wants to
come home and sleep at my place too but
see alcohol don't want us to sleep in
the bed alcohol wants me to sleep
between my toilet and my [__] sink
with my arm bent around my head well I
throw my nuts up into the toilet
and then on top of it wants to [__] my
night pants
weed ain't [__] my night pants
get up in the morning you don't even
remember what the [__] happened to
people have to prompt you not weed weeds
up weed's been up
we'd have breakfast we'd had coffee we
took a morning [__]
weeds out walking the dog smoking a
joint because that's how chill weed is
that smokes itself
now I know you guys are in here drinking
I want you to drink I want you to have a
good time we're here to have fun but I
also want you to get home safe all right
so let's have an adult conversation
because it's us against those cops out
there that's it that's what it is okay
and you're not gonna pass those tests
they're not designed for us to pass all
right and I don't know about you guys
but anytime I've been drinking alcohol
and the cops show up alcohol don't want
to cooperate alcohol likes me to talk a
little [__]
cop show up alcohol be like
cops
how many of them is it
[Music]
I think we could take them
Ryan
I know you don't want to hear this but
if I see an opening
I'm going for his gun shut the [__] up
alcohol
we're not over any cops good
and then you gotta pass those tests you
ain't passing those tests that cop say
to me sir I'm gonna need you to walk
this line alcohol be like
walk it I'm a cartwheel down this
[__]
I'ma hit you with a round off at the end
show you who's boss
let's do this you open that door up poop
face down
and then your arms naturally float up
okay it's an easy handcuff it's a free
knee in the neck they're tasering me I'm
pissing on myself it's all right here on
body cam footage and they're watching it
at the precinct laughing at me I'm not
going out like that okay
and if I was that high behind the wheel
we wouldn't even let me drive we'd be
like Ryan seriously what the [__] are
you doing dude all over
this is a great time to catch up on some
calls
organize this glove box
and figure out how to fix the clock on
this [__] radio I'm like God damn we
thought of everything man let's pull
over see how Grandma's doing
look I know weed's not for everyone
because I've eaten it before too okay
now it's amazing to me that that same
[__] plan someone should tell us in
elementary school that hey if you smoke
that and you eat that it's two different
planets okay
now I'm not bulletproof a few years ago
my cousin was turning 40 and he called
me up and he's like look this birthday's
got me feeling my age and I would really
like to go do something just the two of
us let's go do something like we used to
do
When We Were Young and I go all right I
was excited I was like what do you want
to do and he goes why don't we ride
roller coasters and I was like I'll know
about that
these roller coasters today they're not
like the ones when we grew up and he's
like you're saying we're old I guess not
what I'm saying but forget I said it
we're gonna make a day out of it and we
did the two of us went out to Six Flags
Magic Mountain yeah right here in
Valencia California one of the best
roller coaster parks in the world
and we got there right at 9am when the
park opened
he pulls in a parking space he throws
the car and park and he looks over at me
and he goes hey
and it was a shady hay
okay
sound a lot like an alcohol hey if I'm
being honest
and he goes we should eat these before
we go in there
he holds up these two brownies okay look
they're about this big
that's not that bad they're about this
thick and I'm like dude there is no
[__] way I'm going in that Park Until
both those brownies are gone
[Applause]
and we each have a full marijuana
brownie and we venture inside the park
and we get in line for the very first
ride of the day
a roller coaster called Tatsu okay
great don't worry if you don't know
about it I'm about to walk you through
this [__]
now we wait in line for 45 minutes
45 minutes coincidentally
happens to be the perfect amount of time
for that we eat brownie to give me
incredible anxiety
okay and not just about this roller
coaster I'm watching go by every
decision I've ever made in my life
I'm Shuffling along and weird shits just
dialing up you know I'm like
huh
why do I wash my hands before I do dirty
dishes
[Laughter]
what the hell happened to tan M MS
yeah
all right by round of applause how many
people in here remember tan M M's
that is not everybody
[Applause]
some of y'all been living among us in a
tanless Eminem World
I'll tell you what the [__] happened to
tan Eminem's
1995.
Mars candy decides that two Browns are
redundant
they kill off the pans
said they opened a vote to all of us
said we voted blue I didn't vote for
[__]
they killed tan M M's and that is what
happened I looked it up for this joke
I wanted to be funny and factual
all right let's get in line for tattoo
because we're next
so I step in now you start standing and
I say this little high school kid I'm
like yo where do we sit and he goes well
you start standing I said we started
doing that 45 minutes ago [__]
[Applause]
and I take that bar and I pulled over my
chest now I don't know what your
Technique is for this but this one's
mine I pull it so that it's far enough
out and I don't feel immediately
claustrophobic I don't feel trapped okay
I want to ease myself into this
situation
okay and then I lean back against the
back rest and I fall forward to the
shoulder harness and I gauge how many
more clicks I need on my level of fear
right so I'll be like
that's two
click click
there's one click oh we're good right
there it's a three Clicker
I got room in there I don't feel trapped
or claustrophobic I feel secure but I
hear this voice say hey man I think we
could slide out of this
I was like okay good my cousin's going
through exactly what I'm going through
and I look over at my cousin and he
didn't say [__]
but this time I hear it again with a
sense of urgency out here hey man I
think we can slide out of this and I was
like
oh my God
it's the weed brownie talking to me
right now
and it's as scared as I am
and I took comfort in that
and I had an inner dialogue back with
the Wii brownie I was like you think we
could slide out of this he's like yeah I
definitely think we could slide out of
this I was like but do you really think
I should say something to somebody who's
like [__] yeah say something to somebody
but what I didn't realize is I have been
saying all of that out loud
[Applause]
and the young high school kid comes by
and this kid he Bruce Lee's my bar
okay two clicks too tight and I lose my
[__]
I'm like I don't want to do this
I'm pretty sure I don't want to do this
some guy up front's like dude swallow
your pride
and I was like hey dick I did when I
started crying
these two saloon doors close over my
chest
a bar hits me across my knees they lower
us we're hanging now only connected by a
bar from our spine to the track there's
nothing under us I feel like I'm in a
pterodactyl claw getting ready to be
flown off for breakfast
and I like to think that I'm a man I
like to think I'm strong but I'm not
even gonna lie to you I was hanging in
that tunnel I was scared I didn't know
what to do and I just started hard
blinking I was like
and I just had this Moment of clarity
where I was like get a hold of yourself
you [__] you have weed all the time you
just ate it you're fine look at your
cousin he's probably fine and I'll look
over at my cousin my cousin is laser
focused he looks like a pointer dog he's
like
and if I'm being honest he looks like he
died two days ago
but he's dialed in I go back to freaking
the [__] out I'm like oh my God
it is 9 53 A.M
they shoot us out of this tunnel
up this hill that's so [__] high
I swear I saw two birds
that were like you gotta be [__]
laughs
and right at the top of the hill my
cousin snaps out of and he looks over at
me goes I want out
but now dude you suck at this
it was 14 Loops in like three seconds it
was simulated death on a roller coaster
and we were done I'm not embarrassed to
tell you I had to get help out of there
okay I took a knee I was like oh my God
I'll get off oh [__]
oh
this is a biker Cosmo my whole life
right here
I make terrible decisions terrible just
one after the other
and I slowly got up and my cousin came
over
and angrily
he said I'm sorry
[Applause]
maybe we are too old for this
and I said no we're not we're too high
for this no doubt about that but we're
not too old for this I'm trying to tell
you these aren't the roller coasters of
yesteryear okay basically a Decepticon
just raped Us in the sky
and Magic Mountain should thank us for
not [__] on this quadrant of their
Park
and we hit the bumper cars and the log
flume and called it a day
[__] that soup
[Applause]
you know I came here tonight to do this
special and I came here I didn't really
think I was going to tell this story but
looking into your eyes y'all look like
you've seen some [__]
so I feel like this is a safe space to
tell these stories
um all right this is a genuine question
and I do want to hear Applause if this
is true for you if it resonates for you
okay but listen to the whole question
all right
how many people in this room have ever
been in a ride share situation Uber Lyft
taxi whatever and genuinely thought this
person's gonna kill me
listen to that
okay in a room this size I thought under
five people
okay I've been telling this story across
North America on this tour
they're definitely trying to kill us
y'all it's this every [__] night
every night now I had a couple weird
things happen to me I'm gonna share how
I handled it maybe it's something you
could take out in your world maybe it's
even something that could save your life
so a few years ago
I was in Phoenix flying back to LA after
some shows and I ordered myself an Uber
XL now I always get an Uber XL not
because I have any extra money but
because I believe my chances of
surviving in a bigger car are better
than dying in this lunatics Prius okay
so that extra eleven dollars is worth
the investment in me right
so it says that I'm getting a silver
Ford Edge and it says it's being driven
by this really young white kid and I
want to emphasize young white kid like
this kid was like like Duke University
white okay like that you know what this
kid was white okay you gotta hit the H
on this [__] he was white okay
and license plate whatever ABC one two
three so my phone buzzes now I step
outside I'm looking for a silver Ford
Edge driven by a young white kid
and this Mexican dude pulls up okay I
mean tatted neck and chest and a lowered
black Chevy Silverado and aggressively
hits the brakes and that truck dips down
and he waits till it rocks all the way
and then he goes it's me
and I was like who the [__] are you
he goes I'm your Uber I said
you don't look anything like Toby
and he goes I got a new car I go it's
not the car I'm worried about
okay get the [__] out of here go kill
somebody else
I told that story recently Adam Karen
come up to me after the show
yeah and she got all up in my face and
she goes you know that story you told
about the Uber driver was racist and I
said what part about that was racist she
goes how do you know he was Mexican
I said oh
I'll tell you how I know he was Mexican
Karen
he had a portrait of the Last Supper
airbrushed on his tailgate
that's how the [__] I know he was
Mexican Karen
you coming at the wrong one Karen
I happen to be a fan of airbrush
tailgates
and only Mexicans are keeping them alive
and I would simply like to say gracias
okay
I live right here too I've seen some
beautiful Jesus pieces in traffic all
around Southern California so maybe
you're the racist Karen clearly you've
never been to San Bernardino
[Applause]
it's true I've seen some beautiful
artwork on the back I'm sitting in
traffic sometimes I'm like look at the
rosary around those hands
could see the wood grain in it
I could see the other side through
Jesus's nail holes look at that amazing
oh
all right this was a little more recent
this is only a few months ago
I'm with a friend of mine named Jen all
right Jen's a good friend and Jen and I
go out to Palm Springs now Jen's a
drinker Jen's doing what Jen does Jen's
[__] up okay
somebody's got to be responsible in our
Duo so I'm just smoking weed okay at the
end of the night she's like hey will you
go out and drink with me for a change
and I said yeah I will but let me handle
this you're [__] up I'm gonna take
care of everything so the first thing I
do is I map our route out to the bar I
want to know right where we're going
and I order us an Uber XL this time it
says we're getting an older white guy
with a bushy ponytail
and that just makes my [__] tight
it ain't for me
I don't like it
and it says
he's driving a Chevy Astro van and I'm
like this has got to be a typo right
here
there's no way this dude's about to roll
in here all the way from the 80s
laughs
whatever license plate ABC one two three
my phone buzzes I'm like Jen says our
rides here now we go outside here comes
a Chevy Astro van I'm like you got to be
[__] kidding me right now
now the guy pulls up and there he is
older white dude bushy ponytail
my [__] stays tight
okay now
this is a crucial moment in this
Exchange in our defense a lot of us take
these rides because we are [__] up and
we're trying to do the right thing we're
trying to get home and not hurt anyone
not hurt ourselves being responsible so
in that exchange a lot of times we're
[__] up we don't think straight when
you walk up to that car you make that
driver ask your name you don't just give
it to him you don't walk up and be like
are you here to pick up Gary
you'd be like yeah I'm here to kill Gary
get in Gary yeah it's a free one tonight
Garrett
make him ask your name
this guy goes Ryan I was like
unfortunately yeah
and I just quickly I peeped that front
tag but that's not good enough for me I
want to check the back tag I don't want
any [__] surprises
but Jen is [__] up I grab her by the
shoulders and I'm like listen sway right
here I'll be right back okay
I go I go to the back of the van boom
license plate checks out I turn around
to tell Jen it's already to get in Jen's
gone
I run up to the door she's in slid all
the way over I'm like what are you doing
this is how Dateline starts
I get in
shut the door dude immediately makes a
wrong turn out of the parking lot and I
am on his ass I'm like oh
no we know where we're going
we know where we're going and he starts
stuttering he gets nervous he's like I
uh
I know it's shortcut don't worry I'm
gonna get you there in a jiffy and I
said jiffy
nobody says Jiffy anymore
this son of a [__] is gonna kill us
listen that's right where my mind goes
all right you can judge me all you want
to but I live my life like every gun is
loaded okay every snake is a king cobra
and no matter what touches me in the
ocean it's Jaws okay I know I've had
seaweed hit me in the leg and I'm like
trying to ever try to walk something off
in the ocean you can't look cool doing
that
can't
so now we're rolling along
and Jen's doing what drunk girls do and
Jen's hitting this [__] with a
shitload of unnecessary questions I mean
just what's your shoe size
what are your thoughts on rotisserie
chicken
are you allergic to shellfish I'm like
shut up what the [__] are we doing
it and he goes it's for the gig I go all
right you're in a band or something he
goes nah
this is the gig and I said nah
this is the [__] that's gonna
kill us and now I know I need to act and
I have a plan ready so I'm trying to
lock eyes with Jen okay so finally I get
Jen's attention like Jen switch and
she's like what
I go go over let me go under boom Jen
goes over I go under and now I
intentionally lock eyes with him in that
rear view mirror and I'm like yeah
that was weird wasn't it
you're up there doing weird [__] we're
back here doing weird [__]
I know you want to know why I moved and
there are two reasons the first reason
and this is just brutal honesty if he
pulls out a gun he's going right here
first okay
listen this is no one's primary shot
okay bullets are expensive and that's
not a guarantee okay this is a pop-up
pop you can keep piecing your hand make
a left if that motherfucker's built
different you could swing back around
pop they're gone okay
and yes I know that's [__] up Jen is a
really good friend of mine
okay but like I told Jen somebody's got
to tell this story
and in this story I'm the Storyteller
Jen's the drunk chick okay and the last
thing I need is some drunk chick telling
everybody How I died in a Chevy Astro
van in 2022 okay it's gonna be a lot of
holes in her story and my body
now the other reason
is because of this belt right here
y'all see this belt this belt and I go
back to the late 1900s
I got this belt in 1996.
the late 1900s
and I've had it reinforced three times
and I don't wear it to hold up my pants
it's not a fashion statement I don't
care if it matches my shoes
I wear this belt in case I need to kill
a [__]
and tonight's my lucky night
so what am I gonna do I'll show you what
the [__] I'm gonna do
remember
we're an Astro van
so I'm gonna sit behind them
I'm gonna put my foot up on that back
seat just for good [__] leverage you
know I mean like I really want to get in
there now some of you know some of you
might not know but in college I was all
Juco soccer I'm doubling up on that
[__] seat I still got plenty of
muscle memory left
and I'm taking my belt I'm a lasso right
over his head and I'm gonna crank on
that motherfucker's neck and I must pull
myself but I must say pull over and I'll
let you
pulled over and I'll let you live
you better do it to Jiffy
[Applause]
and as soon as he pulls over I'm yanking
on that belt like Santa just passed a
good kid's house like
[__] that hole I'm using the hole that I
made
yeah with that junk drawer screwdriver
when I lost 15 pounds in 2005. the whole
they seated like today in a little while
but being honest that's the whole museum
and just as I get set he says you're
here
and I said you're a lucky [__]
and I got out of that Astro van I wasn't
done I did that [__] my dad used to do
to intimidate me I stood in his
headlights and I just
[Applause]
that store
you're welcome stay strapped y'all stay
strapped
stay strapped
all right
I mentioned earlier I'm a single dad now
I have a daughter who's eight and her
brother just turned 18. okay it's my
stepson this kid's been in my life since
he was five and
I'm having a problem with him right now
because he just turned 18 and I remember
turning 18 you know you feel like a man
you think you might be a little stronger
you can you can take the old man
the problem I'm having with him is he
shot up to six five okay yeah I'm five
ten he's six five now he's built like a
praying mantis okay real lean no no meat
on him
so there's two things he's doing to me
around the house right now to establish
his dominance under the same roof
one of them is he likes to walk past me
and literally look down at me
and head faked me like that that's his
move okay but walking by me and just
head faking me like that because he
wants to see weakness he wants to see me
Flinch and I'll tell you all what I told
him I don't get scared I get startled
big difference between those two words
you ask anybody who's ever been a fight
turn around look for their friends
scared they're gone they ran startled if
I'm with you I'll just pick what the
[__] happened oh [__] okay okay you
want some okay just need to get my
bearings about me and I'm up for cuts
and elbows all the way down
startled not scared
the other thing and this is only a guy
thing too loves to walk by me and act
like he's gonna backhand my ball bag
like loves him loves it see listen to
the laughter in the room it's Bassy it's
basic because it's only guys that do
this [__]
here's the thing every man in here has
either done it or had it done to him
okay and we don't even get mad I know
one time a guy got me so good he was
like when I was like
whoa
whoa oh I feel that my spinal fluid oh
somebody get a tape measure I might be
six foot for the only time in my life
oh dude right on the tip it stings
it [__] stings
I've had dudes do that to me at the
office yeah at work could you imagine
walking into a store and seeing two
women do that to each other
somebody's just like
[Music]
Daryl
keep wearing those Lululemon so casual
Fridays my backhand that [__] every
Friday Cheryl
and then Kelly's walking back to her
desk the hero to office like yeah yeah I
got a knuckle up in there share
yeah oh Cheryl's got a Brazilian yeah oh
who said they want to smell it oh [__] D
you're terrible D that's why you can't
come to Christmas parties no more d
that's my stepson and that's boys right
I'm all boys I have brothers all my
cousins are boys like I am [__] balls
all the way back to the dick and balls
all right so when I knew I was having a
girl I was excited I knew it would
change me I knew it would change me for
the better I know it will calm me down I
was really looking forward to a whole
different perspective
um so when my daughter was one
her mom and I split now at one I'm a I'm
still a new dad and now I'm a new single
dad okay and I don't know [__] okay I
know nothing but here's what I do know I
want to be a dad I don't want to be some
babysitter so I go to court I fight for
50 50. her mom and I get along we do
great and I've got my daughter all the
time since she's one now I'm every
diaper I broke the pacifier every doctor
appointment everything and I say that so
that you know I am [__] in this but I
have no
listen
I just I genuinely appreciate that but I
didn't say it for cheap Applause I
really said it to set up this next story
so
because I want you to know how in this I
am but I have no idea what the [__] I'm
doing
at the time my daughter's three and
we're getting the bath ready and I turn
the water on she goes dad can I get in
while the water's running I go yeah I
turn around to grab something and when I
turn back around my beautiful
three-year-old daughter is in the crab
walk position with her vagina under the
faucet
and I'm like hey
what's going on in here
very innocently she's like I'm cleaning
my vagina and I go okay
I'm new at this
but I'm pretty sure we don't need the
power wash it
[Applause]
I got a window in my bathroom
my neighbor hears that [__] and she
yells him what the hell's going on in
there
I said wow to mind your [__] business
Teresa
at me like that and I said well for
being honest I'm insecure and I don't
really know what the hell I'm looking at
and she goes well it sounds like she's
cleaning her vagina yes what she said
she goes what's the big deal I'm 63 and
I still do that so we don't need to know
that about you Teresa
[Music]
now go back to this
and I don't know what the [__] I'm
looking at
I don't know I'm Googling [__] you know
I'm panicking I don't know what to do
okay but I do know what I'm not gonna do
I'm not gonna make fun of her I'm not
going to tease her I'm going to fight
everything in me and I'm just going to
attack this with positivity
and as a man who makes my living using
my words I don't always say the right
thing
and I came out of the gate with
man
that thing's really taking a beating huh
that's what I said
and I was embarrassed
I was embarrassed but not because of
what I said I was embarrassed because of
what I forgot I forgot the strength of a
woman I watched that little girl come
out of her mom's body I was like yeah
[__] women are powerful you know and
now here's where I made my mistake
I'm not expecting this to be some
seasoned veteran vagina you know what I
mean I don't know what I'm doing this
thing hasn't gone through pregnancies
and periods and yeast infections and all
this [__] you poor ladies got to go
through I thought this thing was a a new
Desert Rose
I thought we had to be soft
and gentle
my daughter's water boarding it for 20
minutes under the [__] faucet
and I don't care one man in here so
whatever you give me your ball back give
me the most seasoned veteran ball bag in
this building night and we put under
that water pressure I saw and your ball
starts spinning like this you'll be like
oh wow
[Music]
oh please I'll tell you all my secrets
oh God I stole Grandma's wedding ring I
stole Grandma's wedding ring
and finally I just reached in and I was
like that's enough of that
and I go hey
do you do that at Mom's
and she goes she doesn't have this kind
of water pressure
so definitely tried it
but if you're keeping score at home
dad's got better water pressure all
right I don't know how to feel about
that but I'm competitive as [__] and I'm
taking the points all right
good
and at the end of that it's quiet and
through my bathroom window I hear you
did good dad
yeah and I was like [__] you Teresa [__]
you and your aggressive vaginal hygiene
habits
stay the [__] out of my window Teresa
all right
do you guys like to get scared do you
like to be scared yeah all right this is
a story of the most scared I've ever
been in my life all right now it starts
with a question and I really do want you
to Applause if this is something that is
true for you how many people in this
room have ever had to sneak someone back
into a mental institution
all right I'll go first
okay
so quick back story on me if you don't
know I'm raised by a single dad my mom
had left our family early on
and at 16 my dad dies so the state puts
us back with our mom and our mom if
nothing was consistent and she
immediately moved out okay she did moved
in with her boyfriend so the three of us
live in this small apartment by
ourselves now we happen to live a
quarter of a mile from a mental
institution called Springfield mental
hospital okay we have friends moms who
work there one of our friends moms was a
nurse Rita lamb and Miss Reed used to
tell us all the time because we would
drive through this mental hospital and
she'd be like you shouldn't be doing
that at night we're like why and she's
like because of the lady and we're like
who she's like the lady look who the
[__] is the lady she's like don't clown
the lady she's real and at the most
inopportune times when you're least
expecting it she'll dive on the [__]
hood of your car and we're like get the
[__] out of here
now you can't tell some 16 year old kids
who don't have parents and do have a
driver's license some [__] like that not
expect us to drive through Springfield
for the next [__] two years every
night looking for the lady
now I want to explain this mental
hospital it's more like a junior college
almost it's a campus okay it's got a
double yellow line through it down here
on this end are people who wear
wristbands and they're allowed to walk
the property on this end are people who
are like I can't get out of this jacket
okay that's our range on this property
they also happen to have a prison right
behind it it's a minimum security prison
a laundry facility these guys do the
laundry for the mental hospital and fun
fact they have a softball team called
the dirty socks
swear to God I've seen two of their
games every game's a home game y'all
senior year comes and we're told by the
school that we're getting these foreign
exchange students okay they're from
Korea and we're told that they're
Olympians and we're like whoa [__] yeah
we're getting Olympians like yup and
their names are Carlos and Eddie Co I
don't know who the [__] named these kids
but that's how they're introduced to our
school and when I said well what sport
do they play the teacher said ping pong
and I was like can we pump the brakes on
Olympian like for real here like
now they tell us and they tell us Point
Blank me and my brothers they're like
hey don't get these kids in trouble
they're Olympians they're here for a
special purpose their Olympic I hear
what the [__] you're saying okay you're
saying we don't have parents and don't
[__] these kids up like life [__] ours
up
okay you're saying these kids get [__]
we don't get like hugs
and breakfasts
[Laughter]
now Carlos and Eddie are there to train
at this world-class ping pong facility
we had in Maryland that no one knew we
had because no one gave a [__] about
ping pong like that
and they're housed at Springfield mental
hospital now hear me out they're all the
way in an old dorm down here on the left
where the wristband people are okay
now
Carlos was the more reserved one he uh
was very by the book was always back on
time for curfew but Eddie Eddie was just
like us okay now I don't know if any of
you had these kids in your high school
but we are the kids with no parents and
people at our house Monday to Sunday
okay for years all right so Eddie didn't
speak the same language at all but
energy doesn't lie man Eddie was young
like us and wanted to have fun so he's
always partying with us and there's been
a few times we've gotten a back pass
curfew and now they're starting to warn
us that hey if Eddie gets one more
[__] late
he could lose his spot on the Olympic
team we're like that's [__] up man so
they tell us don't [__] with them don't
[__] with them
so March of 1991 we're all partying at
my place full moon is out there's a nice
little dusting of snow on the ground and
we let time slip away and I look at the
clock and it's 12 30 and I'm like [__]
and I just walk out to the living room
and I'm like hey
who wants to help me sneak Eddie Co back
into the mental institution
and my friend Eric Snyder goes I got you
we're still friends to this day
and Eric drives a 1980 blue Camaro with
glass t-tops and cow induction okay this
thing was tits
and Eric wouldn't let anybody drive that
car
So the plan is this he's going to drive
I'm going to sit in the passenger seat
Eddie's going to sit in the back seat
we're a quarter of a mile from this
mental hospital we're gonna back out our
little gravel driveway we can drive no
problem off the light of the moon on
that snow so we kill the headlights we
don't need brake lights we're going to
take off for that mental hospital Eric's
got to hit that gas dip down the hill up
the hill at that point we're going to
come in front of Eddie's dorm now I'm
going to open the door now you know the
light's going to go off and back then
some of those cars would also just go
for no [__] reason
okay so all that's going to bust us
so we turn that headlight switch we
click it to the left now there's no dome
light there's no buzz we're going to be
rolling slow enough I'm going to open
the door I'm going to lean the seat
forward Eddie's going to jump out while
we're moving all right shouldn't be a
problem he's an Olympian
[Music]
and then he's got to go over here to his
dorm he's got to pull this door if this
door is locked we're [__] and he could
lose his spot on the Olympic team but if
this opens he's in and at least we got
him in and we're good and the last
hurdle of this is we're gonna drift
downhill we gotta pop the clutch okay I
know some of you might not even know
what I'm talking about so I'll explain
it very quickly pop into clutches if you
have a manual car you put your clutch in
you drop it in second as it's rolling
down the hill somewhere around 18 20
miles an hour you let that clutch out
and tap that gas and stealth off into
the [__] night it's the perfect plan
except Eric sucked at popping a clutch
okay I don't know if you've ever tried
it but if you [__] it up it sounds like
someone just shot a coyote it's like
and your car's violent oh God go stop
like we're definitely getting caught
there's Maryland State Police room and
there's the Springfield police Roman and
all we have to do is get down that hill
and we're [__] out and now it's go
time so we all get in the car Eric's
driving I'm in the pastor's seat Eddie's
in the back we back out off that gravel
driveway boom no headlights no brake
lights see fine off the light of that
moon hit that campus Eric punches it
perfect we go right down that Hill up
the hill and right in front of that dorm
where the turnabout is we pull up now I
throw the door open No Light No buzzer I
lean the seat up Eddie Co jumps out
sticks The Landing okay I'm all excited
I'm like
[Music]
oh
and Eddie goes back to the dorm and he's
got to pull this door open and again if
it doesn't open doesn't [__] matter
and he pulls it and it [__] opens and
he throws us the biggest thumbs up we're
like yeah yeah [__] yeah perfect
[__] plan
last hurdle you gotta pop that clutch
Eric and Eric looks at me and he goes
I'm scared
I go I know you are dude but just listen
I'm gonna walk you through it put the
clutch in and when I say now you let it
out tap that gas and work on he's like
all right we start rolling down that
hill right around 20 miles an hour I
look at him and I'm like now and when
Eric lets that clutch out boom
on the glass t-tops it's the latest
hello right now and she's up on those
glass t-tops and she's like yeah
yeah
look again I like to think I'm a man but
the first thing I said was
Eric Eric looked right back at me
I said kill this [__]
and I'm tearing the property up I'm
grabbing a wheel I'm like hit the gas
hit the brakes throw off run her over
back up peel out on her and run over
again kill this [__] and she's up there
like Terminator yeah ah banging like ah
all right she was about to come through
the glass I took my belt off let's go
choke that [__] upside down
goddamn
[Applause]
just beating on that guy he's like ah
yeah
oh the police come everyone's coming
I finally look up through the glass and
there's a Korean face staring back at me
and it's Eddie Coe
Eddie Coe forgot his gym bag in the back
seat
and we had told the story of the lady to
Eddie Coe and Eddie Co thought that [__]
would be hilarious
[Applause]
tonight it is
that night it was not hilarious
okay I don't know how many of y'all have
ever had a Korean Olympic Committee
looking at your background but
I have a file
we were immediately and promptly
separated never to see one another again
we all graduated without incident and we
went on to try to find edico now this
was 91 internet's not till 96. can't
find them none of us have been able to
find them but I want to say one thing
for real I clowned them about being an
Olympian
but the way he held onto that car that
night
he held on like an Olympian y'all at the
minimum edico deserves a gold medal long
live edico
okay
I talk a lot about
uh being from Baltimore and I really
genuinely believe that I'm lucky to be
from that specific city as a kid with my
story so having no parents at 16 I'm
looking for wisdom I'm looking for
knowledge I'm looking for any leg up I
can get in life and I listen to everyone
and being from Baltimore I've been very
fortunate to be friends with and work
with some older black men and I'm going
to tell you all right now nobody's got
the wisdom of an old black man nobody
they have been places I'll never be
they have seen things I'll never see and
they've done things I'll never do so
anytime an older black man will pull me
to the side to drop some knowledge I was
all ears
I didn't always know what the hell they
were talking about
but I didn't know there was truth in
there and I'm gonna share my favorites
with you tonight maybe again something
you could take out in your world
so 23 years old
I'm going to college all right my Monday
to Friday is 7 A.M to 3 P.M I go to
college 3 P.M I leave College I drive
down to Baltimore city and I work at UPS
shout out to UPS Baltimore Hub primary
one Joe Avenue okay
that's when I'm there
and I work the graveyard shift I start
around four o'clock work till two or
three in the morning and I've got this
older black man named John Lewis who's
training me on the job and John Lewis
isn't just training me about this job
John Lewis is teaching me about life he
also happens to be Reggie Lewis's Uncle
I know some of you NBA fans remember
Reggie who unfortunately passed he's a
Baltimore kid he's a big deal there's a
museum there this is his uncle always
rocking that gold Celtics Medallion
always telling me like family stories
I'm not going to hear on a [__] 30
for 30. you know what I mean I'm
enamored with this guy so one Friday
night I come in and John Lewis goes
Brian
what are you doing you get off tonight
and like I said it could be three or
four in the morning I was like
I don't know I'm probably just going to
smoke a joint and go to bed what about
you John Lewis and he leans in and he
goes I'm gonna [__] my wife
I was like oh my God
it's like that John Lewis
I'm like what are you a newlywed or some
[__] and he goes no I've been with the
same woman for over 30 years I go holy
[__]
at your age you're still [__] like
that at four in the morning
you got to teach a young man the secret
right now
and he leans in he goes Ryan
you got to make that [__] pop
and the way he yelled pop
and the way I jumped
I knew I had never made a [__] pop
I don't even know what the [__] he was
talking about
and I was scared to interrupt them
because he broke out into a dance right
on the spot he was like yeah
ah somebody out here was like I know
that I'm like I don't know what the [__]
anyone is talking about at all right now
but what I do know
is the secret to longevity in your
relationships it's [__] popping okay
so when you get out of here and I get
home pop those [__] fall in love all
over again all right that's what I want
for you
[Applause]
yeah they're your [__] cheer for them
all right
no parents working every day same age 23
I just told you about my Monday to
Friday my Saturday and Sunday
is I'm a delivery driver for a junkyard
all right now if you don't know about
junk yards junkyards are some of the
most crooked businesses in our country
all right in the hierarchy of scumbags
in this country it goes Catholic Church
politics
NCAA junkyards okay
[__] the NCAA I hate those Crooks
so my job as a delivery driver I am
delivering Motors Transmissions Parts
all over Maryland Virginia D.C West
Virginia and one day they tell me that I
need to go to Baltimore city to pick up
this specialist named meso now I've
never met meso but made so specialty is
rolling back odometers okay
now I know some of you don't know what
I'm talking about so I'm gonna make this
make sense real quick for all of us
let's say collectively we own a 1990
Honda Civic with original rims as for
the OG's right there
and let's say that car has 200 000 miles
on it if meso rolls it back to say a
hundred thousand we're doubling our
money on that car right so they tell me
I need to go pick Mesa up one day and
I've never met meso and I'm going to a
neighborhood in Baltimore city that you
might recognize from The Wire okay I
have no business in this neighborhood
but your boy's got business in this
neighborhood and I'm sitting out front
waiting for meso to come out of the
house this tall slender black man comes
out he's got a Kang on and he's not
carrying a toolbox this dude's got one
of those alligator doctor house call
bags you know I'm talking about that
little and I was like oh this is a bad
[__] right here
so he gets in and I drive him out to the
junkyard now I'm dying to ask him about
what he does because I love the Criminal
Mind but I don't have the balls to jump
right into it so I drop him off and he
goes about his day rolling back
odometers and I go about my day
delivering parts and at the end of the
day they tell me I need to take meso
back home and I've tried to work up the
courage to talk to him about what he
does
and I'm driving them back and I puss out
a straight up puss out we get to the
front of his place and he opens the car
door and he puts one foot out and I go
meso hold up just tell me a little bit
about what you do
and in that brief conversation I say man
that's something and he leans back in
and he goes that ain't [__]
he goes you want to know what something
is and I leaned in and I was like
[__] yeah I wanna know what song is he
goes all right then
next time your dick's hard I was like
wait what
hold on a second Matt
we've been talking about odometers all
this time
and now you got my dick hard and I don't
know how you're gonna roll that back
and he got mad he goes you wanna know
what's up man and I got scared I was
like yeah I'm sorry but please I need to
know what something is goes all right
there
next time your dicks hard
put it in your left hand
then put your right one over it
he goes if there's anything still
sticking out of the top that's something
got the [__] out of the car and I never
saw him again
he said that's what he [__] said
and I'm gonna be honest with y'all
I don't know
if that's the dumbest [__] I've ever
heard in my life
or if it's the smartest [__] I've ever
but I'd be a liar
if I didn't tell y'all that that night
when I went home
you bet your ass I try to see if I had a
little something
I had all my dick skin pulled back I was
like oh my God
I think I got five skin here but I'm
so ladies
when you're home tonight
getting ready to get your [__] popped
and your man's taken a lot longer in the
bathroom and that's definitely going to
happen
just please cut him some slack he's
trying to see if he's got a little
something all right Los Angeles
thank you so much I'm Ryan sickler thank
you
foreign